and we are staying on the health tip
right now southwest medical wants to
remind you how important breast care and
awareness is
they have several locations where you
can get the proper screenings done so
here's more information
so we're talking breast care and
mammographies of course you guys have us
covered at southwest medical so
just get to the basics of breast cancer
care in general
sure so um breast cancer in general it's
you know a
really important issue for women not
counting some
kinds of skin cancer breast cancer in
the u.s
is the most common in women no matter
your race or background
and among women in nevada it's estimated
that over 2300 cases will be diagnosed
this year alone
what we do is we promote screening
obviously so screening is checking a
woman's breasts for cancer before
there's any signs or symptoms of the
disease
and although breast cancer screening
cannot prevent breast cancer it can help
find breast cancer early
when it's easier to treat so people
should women should talk to their doctor
about which you know cancer screening
tests
are right for you and when you should
have them done
for sure and what about mammograms um so
mammograms um it's an x-ray of the
breast uh for many women
mammograms are the best way to find
cancer early
when it's easier to treat and um before
it's big enough to cause symptoms
um also having regular mammograms lower
the risk of
dying from breast cancer currently
having a mammogram is the best way to
find it for most women
okay and what should we expect when we
go into a mammogram how does it work
um so first off you want to make sure
you don't wear deodorant powders or
lotions
um also try to wear a two-piece piece
clothing on the day of your mammogram
just makes it easier for the
technologist
um then a specifically trained
radiologist technologist
will perform the x-ray it's really fast
um the compression might be a little
painful but it's necessary to produce
the best picture
um using the lowest amount of radiation
possible signs to look for would be a
lump in your breast
um which is the most common symptom
swelling in or around your breast
collarbone or armpits
if the skin of your breast starts to
feel like an orange peel
or it gets red breasts warmth or itching
also change in nipple discharge or
drainage
and new pain in one area although most
breast cancers don't cause
pain some do and lindsay i understand
that southwest medical has an entire
breast care program so what goes into
that
yes we do um so our breast care program
can
can provide instruction how to properly
perform a self-breast exam
we also have clinical breast exams
women ages 40 and older should have a
clinical breast exam
annually when it women 20 to 39
should have an exam every one to three
years
so with mammograms all women ages 40 and
over should have
a mammogram every year women with a
family history of breast cancer should
talk to their providers about
when they should have a mammogram okay
and where can we get mammograms here in
town
so screening mammograms are available at
our oaky eastern
north china siena nellis tropicana
and summerlin healthcare centers all
right as you can see southwest medical
has locations across southern nevada all
you got to do is call 702-877-5
to schedule a screening or visit
smalv.com
we'll be right back